partial sum of the series we're going
from one to infinity summing it up of a
sub n is given by and they tell us the
formula for the sum of the first n terms
and they say write a rule for the for
what the actual nth term is going to be
now to help us with this let me just
create a little visualization here so if
i have a sub 1 plus a sub 2 plus
a sub 3 and i keep adding
all the way to a sub n minus 1 plus
a sub n
this whole thing this whole thing that i
just
wrote out
that is s sub n this whole thing is s
let me
this whole thing is s sub n which is
equal to n plus 1 over n plus 10.
now if i want to figure out a sub n
which is the goal of this exercise well
i could subtract out the sum of the
first n minus 1 terms
so i could subtract out
this
so that is s
that is
s
sub n minus 1. and what would that be
equal to well wherever we see an n we'd
replace with an n minus 1 so it'd be n
minus 1 plus 1
over
n minus 1 plus 10 which is equal to
n
over n plus 9. so if you subtract the
red stuff from the blue stuff all you're
going to be left with is the thing that
we want to solve for you're going to be
left with a sub n
so we could write down
a sub n
is equal to s sub n
is equal to s sub n
minus s sub n minus 1
s sub n minus 1. or we could write that
is equal to
this stuff so this is the n plus 1
over n plus 10
minus
minus
n over n plus 9. and this by itself this
is a rule for a sub n but we could
combine these terms add these two
fractions together and this is actually
going to be the case for n greater than
1. for n equals 1 s sub 1 is going to be
well you can just
a sub 1 is going to be equal to s sub 1
but then for any other n we could use
this right over here and if we want to
simplify this well we can add these two
fractions
we can add these two fractions by having
a common denominator so let's see if we
multiply the numerator denominator here
times n plus 9 we are going to get
so this is equal to
n plus 1 times n plus 9
over
n plus 10
times n plus 9.
and from that we are going to subtract
let's multiply the numerator and
denominator here by n plus 10. so we
have n
times n plus 10
over
n
plus 9 times n plus 10.
n plus 9 times n plus 10. and what does
that give us so
let's see if we simplify up here we're
going to have this is n squared
plus 10 n
plus 9 that's that
and then this right over here is n
squared plus oh this is n squared plus
10 n
let me do that red color
so this is
n squared plus 10 n and remember we're
going to subtract this and so when we
are close to deserving a drum roll a sub
n is going to be equal to our
denominator right over here is n plus 9
times n plus 10
and we're going to subtract the red
stuff from the blue stuff so you
subtract an n squared from an n squared
those cancel out subtract a 10n from a
10n those cancel out and you're just
left with that blue 9.
so there you have it we have expressed
we've written a rule for a sub n for n
greater than 1.